-An upcoming book reveals
shocking new details about the
Trump administration's
criminally negligent
COVID response
and Republicans blocked
a voting rights bill
as part of their ongoing attempt
to dismantle our democracy.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As eager as we all are
to get back to normal,
we can't lose sight of the fact
that the COVID pandemic
is still very much with us.
Vaccination rates in parts
of the country are lagging;
case numbers, in some states,
are rising;
a dangerous new variant is
driving up infections in the UK;
and models predict a possible
surge of cases in the fall.
And, even as things
get better, overall,
there are still
constant reminders
of how much our world has
changed in the last 16 months.
Every time I reach across the
counter at my local coffee shop
to grab my iced oat latte
from the barista,
only to accidentally punch
the Plexiglas partition
that's still there to stop the
spread of contagious droplets
from a deadly disease,
I think to myself,
"Oh, right, COVID."
Not that, I should note,
the glass does anything.
I'm pretty sure aerosols
can find their way
around a glass partition.
It's like trying to keep ants
out of your house with a sign.
We're also constantly reminded,
even five months
after he left office,
that Trump's response
to the pandemic
was, somehow,
much worse and much crazier
than we even knew at the time.
Every day, we keep hearing
new details
about his time in office,
thanks to what seems like
a never-ending parade
of tell-all books
scheduled for publication,
each filled with more
damning new details
about just how much
of a sociopath he was.
There are so many Trump books
on the shelves
that he's bleeding
into other books.
The other day, my son found him
next to Waldo.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
He's right here, kid.
He's right here.
And they all have titles
that make them sound
like straight-to-DVD
Steven Seagal movies --
"Nightmare Scenario,"
"Inflection Point,"
"Tipping Point,"
"Hoax," "Rage,"
"Fear," "Fire," "Fury,"
"Fire and Fury"...
I mean, do these people
actually read these?
We all lived with a knot
in our belly for four years.
Who wants to read an 800-page
deep dive about that?
It'd be like reading
a book called...
Maybe they're all just
those cut-out books
you can use to hide your weed
from your dog walker.
Besides, don't we all just get
the craziest tidbits
cherry-picked for us on Twitter
or cable news
or from late night talk shows?
Oh, and speaking of which,
here's a cable news clip
with a tidbit
from a new Trump tell-all.
-Stunning revelations
this morning
about the Trump
administration's response
during the early days
of the pandemic.
In a new book, entitled
"Nightmare Scenario,"
Washington Post journalists
Yasmeen Abutaleb
and Damian Paletta report
how President Trump suggested
sending Americans with COVID-19
to Guantánamo Bay.
-The book draws
on early conversations,
as told by staffers
and government leaders,
like this one, when White House
officials debated
whether to bring infected
Americans home...
-Only Trump would refer
to Guantánamo Bay
as "an island that we own."
It's such a reminder
that he will always,
first and foremost,
be a real estate guy.
Also, Guantánamo Bay
is not an island, you dolt.
It's right there in the name.
It's a naval base and detention
camp on the island of Cuba.
An island we do not own
because --
and I'm not a history buff,
but I think this is right --
JFK couldn't pass
the co-op board.
I will say,
it would've been hilarious,
watching Trump try
to rebrand Guantánamo
as a fun place
for people to spend a week.
[ As Trump ]
Welcome to Guantána-Lago
Spa & Resort.
Make sure you check out the bay.
I heard it is full of pigs.
[ Laughter ]
Also, was there like
a fantasy football draft,
but for the stories each staffer
got to tell for their books?
"I can't decide between the time
he wanted to send cruise ship
passengers to Gitmo
or the time he asked if he
could legally send SEAL Team Six
to rough up Lorne Michaels."
[ As Michaels ]
So, I'm up late,
[ Laughter ]
reading a first edition
Evelyn Waugh,
and I see that little red dot
on the wall
that they have
on sniper rifles
and, from that moment, I knew --
it's SEAL Team Six.
[ Laughter ]
The Trump era was a catastrophe
of unprecedented proportions
and, yet, Republicans
are hell-bent
on repeating it,
if they get a chance,
that's why they're passing
a barrage
of voter suppression bills
that would allow them
to overturn
future election results
and why they blocked
the For the People
voting rights bill yesterday.
And, yet, even with that
brewing crisis on the horizon,
there's a small group
of Democratic senators
who are still super concerned
with preserving the filibuster
and giving Republicans a veto
over their agenda,
like Arizona
Senator Kyrsten Sinema,
who made some truly
ludicrous arguments
in favor of the filibuster,
in an op-ed earlier this week.
-Kyrsten Sinema wrote
for The Washington Post.
She said...
-Well, that's just
how democracy works.
You pass laws and then,
if your opponents take power,
they can change those laws,
unless you rally
public opinion to your side,
which is your job
as a politician.
Didn't any of you people watch
"Schoolhouse Rock" as a kid?
Although I'm guessing,
in Sinema's case,
she watched more,
I don't know,
music videos by ska bands?
She looks like she's going
to a Mighty Mighty Bosstones
concert in 1992.
At least, that's
the impression that I get.
[ Knock-knock, chuckle ]
Your job is to make progress
and then fight
to protect that progress
by galvanizing popular support.
You can't just resign yourself
to doing nothing
because Republicans
might eventually
undo whatever bill you pass.
For one thing,
that's not a given.
Republicans couldn't get rid
of Obamacare,
even with a simple majority,
because it was super popular
and people were outraged.
Also, Republicans
don't seem to care
if they get support
from Democrats.
In fact, they're doing
the opposite.
Across the country,
they're passing
voter suppression bills
on party line votes.
-I followed all
of these debates.
They were party line,
simple majority debates
in Georgia, in Arizona...
-Yes, sir.
-...in Florida,
in all of these states,
making it harder to vote.
And Republicans didn't say, "Oh,
what will the Democrats say
about us?
We need bipartisanship."
-[ Laughs ]
-The entire point
of voter suppression is
to make it harder for your
opponents to be able to vote.
And so there's just
two standards here.
There's the game being played
by Republicans in the states,
where they do whatever they can
to undermine democracy.
Then, there's the game
being played
by Democrats in Washington,
where they fail to protect
American democracy
because of these arcane rules
that nobody actually
cares about.
In 100 years, nobody's going
to care about the filibuster,
if the right to vote
is undermined for decades.
-He's right. No one gives
a [bleep] about the filibuster.
Most people don't even know
where it came from,
why it exists,
why it's called a filibuster,
or where that word
even came from.
True story --
it's a Dutch word, vribuyter,
which translates
to "freebooter,"
and was used to mean "pirate."
So, by respecting
the filibuster,
we're loosely
supporting pirates,
which makes sense,
because, basically,
Mitch McConnell's entire career
has been him
boarding the SS Democracy
and saying --
[ As McConnell ]
Uh, I'm the captain now.
[ Laughter ]
Too long a walk to get
to the McConnell impression?
Just long enough?
I hope it was worth it
because it's a real strain
on my vocal cords.
Not the part just now,
the hours of vocal warm-ups.
[ As McConnell ]
Red leather, yellow leather.
Red leather,
yellow leather.
The jolly collie
swallowed a lollipop.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, no one cares
about the filibuster,
and Democrats,
like Sinema and Joe Manchin,
need to stop playing
by different self-imposed rules
than Republicans.
When Trump supporters were
scaling the walls of the Capitol
to overthrow the government,
they weren't like,
"Aw, man, I hope the Democrats
are cool with this.
Should we have invited
some of them?
You know, just for optics?"
The difference
with Republicans
is so infuriating.
Democrats are worried that,
if they lose the next election,
their legislation
could get overturned,
while Republicans
are still trying
to overturn the last election.
In Arizona, the sham election
audit has gotten so insane,
they're hunting for bamboo
ballots and secret watermarks
and sending copies
of voting data
to a mysterious laboratory
in a remote location in Montana.
-On this piece of property,
in a remote part of Montana,
people may, at this very minute,
be analyzing voting data
from the state of Arizona,
as part of the so-called
Arizona audit.
So, as you might expect,
we're left wondering where,
in the state of Montana,
are the copies of this
voting data being analyzed?
Where is the "secure,
powerful lab"?
So could the information
be here?
We could tell you,
as we walk up here,
the first thing you see on this
big piece of land is the sign --
"Private property.
Trespassing for any purpose
is strictly forbidden.
Violators will be prosecuted."
We can't cross this area.
We can show you, though,
from this area,
what looks like a cabin
on this property.
Is this the "secure,
powerful laboratory"?
Is Arizona voting data
inside that cabin?
We just don't know.
But it could be.
-Dude, be careful on the side
of the highway,
or people are going to think
you're a hitchhiker.
"Anderson, I'm currently
in a windowless white van
with a man named Rex, who says
I can crash with him
for the night
and have all
the ice cream I want,
as long as I make a sacrifice
of fresh deer meat
to the wood spirit Galfgamar.
Back to you, Anderson."
That's how insane
things are right now.
CNN reporters are hunting
for voting data
on the side of a highway
three states away
because Republicans shifted
to a secret location
in the middle of nowhere,
with no outside observers,
in the name
of election integrity.
This is all starting to sound
like a storyline
from the next season of "Ozark,"
which, thanks
to his Netflix deal,
stars Barack Obama.
[ As Obama ]
Uh....Laura.
We got to find the ballots,
or the cartel will, uh,
come after us.
"Uh, sir, her character's
name is Wendy."
Well, let's dub it in later.
ADR it!
I'm in a groove.
[ Laughter ]
Every day, we find out more
about just how much
of a nightmare
the Trump era was
and, every day,
Republicans do whatever they can
to force that nightmare
on us again.
They're passing bills
across the country,
making it easier to overturn
the next election,
and sending voting data
to mysterious locations
to overturn the last election.
The guessing game about where
Arizona Republicans sent
all that voting data
is getting so crazy,
eventually,
we're going to have to ask...
-"What about Guantánamo?"
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.